okay welcome back guys this is Eric and
this is actually the start of what I'm
hoping to be as a new series called
answering viewer questions actually I
don't have an official name for it but
it's going to be something along those
lines answering viewer questions asked
I am Rosen I posted a video a few weeks
ago maybe already a month ago of how to
send me your questions because I just
got questions all the time and I made
the video just explaining okay how to
annotate and send me chest study and
since then I've been getting just a ton
of responses from from people sending
all types of questions in terms of their
own games openings also just general
questions like how to get better at
chess so with each video in this this
series I don't know how often I'm gonna
upload videos but I'm gonna try and
answer like one viewer question
extensively and just try and bring value
to to everyone so the first video I'm
going to focus on a question asked by
Lee chest user by the name of sigmaf and
he was asking about a Carlson game and
asking if I can explain why Carlson
played a six on move three in the Queens
gambit declined after d4 d5 c4 e6 nine
of three Carlson played a six which is
perhaps not such a theoretical move but
it is a more trendy move these days now
I should mention the Carlson game was a
blitz game he was playing against
Grandmaster predrag and Nicola CH and
Carlsen just won in in 22 moves he made
it seem like a piece of cake and this
opponent is 2500 level Grandmaster so at
first when you look at a six it just
seems like a complete waste of time I
mean
usually in the opening you should be
developing your minor pieces controlling
the center and in this case across and
just moves the a pawn off one square but
the this is a type of move the more you
look into it the more you realize it
actually has a clear purpose the main
idea is to eventually capture on c4 and
play b5 and as we'll see in this game
this is exactly what Carlson does and he
gets a very very pleasant position but
expanding on the queenside and in
playing Bishop b7 so one one main line
is let's say white plays a move like
Knight c3 then black is actually ready
to take on c4 and hold on to the pawn
after D takes c4 let's say white plays
d4 if I can played b5 and this is
actually a better version of the Queens
gambit accepted because a6 was very
useful b5 comes in if if white wants to
challenge this pawn chain a4 could be
played but then after pawn to b4 black
is quite happy and then move like 92 can
be met with c5 and there's been a number
of games played in this this line before
I'll go ahead here and just show opening
reference this is new for me so let me
try and switch scenes there you go
and people can see that ok there's been
four games played at like the highest
levels and black score is 75% okay three
wins in one draw if we go back even
further I mean black score is quite well
from I think even this position after D
takes e4 yeah all of the lines black is
scoring better than whites which is
usually a pretty good sign so focusing
back on the board
Knight c3 is already not such not such a
great move for a White's like it already
gives black nice chances together a
better position in the opening so that
leaves white with perhaps a couple
options the most principled move here is
to capture on d5 and that's the sound of
the doorbell whenever you write
okay I'm back I'm sorry about that my
brother was at the door with no no house
key so anyway what was I saying
deef yeah see you take t5 is the most
principled move attempting to render a
six just useless given that after okay
after you take t5 black no longer has
any immediate ideas of playing b5 the
benefit that Black has in this position
though is that this bishop has a
diagonal to develop too and even though
white gets a lead in development let's
say white plays Knight c3 then black can
usually just develop with with ease
actually starting with a move like c6
defending d5 preparing Bishop d6 and
blacks development scheme usually
involves Bishop d6 97 castling and then
waiting to develop this Bishop sometimes
a bishop cose six Queen goes to c7 and
other Knight goes to d7 and eventually
f6 and there's been the number of games
played from from this position Carlson
has actually played this a few times
actually just once he'd be the Aronian
with this in in a crazy blitz game which
if people want to take a look at I'll go
ahead and let me switch scenes again
just to illustrate we can see the
Carlson game here I'll go ahead and cite
this and one thing I didn't mention uh
but I mean this goes without saying is I
will share this this Lee chess study in
the video description so people can
analyze on their own and and delve into
a bunch of different lines a lot more
deeply so it'll be completely public and
accessible and hopefully that will be
good for everyone so going back white
did not go into this instead Nikolic
played a simple move pawn III and this
essentially led into Carlson's plan and
after Pawnee 3a6 made sons and I sense
black played Knight f6 Knight c3 and
Carlson doesn't waste any time here at
Carlson captured on c4 immediately which
actually kind of surprised me because
usually in these structures black should
wait for whites to develop the bishop
before capturing on c4 so black might be
inclined to play a move like Bishop e7
waiting for Bishop e2 and then capture
on c4 so I'm not entirely sure the exact
nuance is why Carlsen didn't didn't play
a move like Bishop e7 maybe he didn't
want white to play b3 and reinforce a
pawn with with the b-pawn so do you take
c4 as will see lead led to very natural
play for for black after Bishop takes C
for the next several moves are just very
natural developing moves pawn b5 Bishop
e2 Bishop to b7 castling 97 Bishop d2
and now now Bishop d6 and this isn't ice
square for the bishop many lines the
bishop ends up on on g7 but in this case
Bishop d6 is just a more active Square
and from this point forward Black has
two main pawn breaks to consider usually
the main one is is c5 but II five as
well as is a very strong potential break
and as we'll see Carlson played that in
a very timely manner
Brooke c1 was played castling and then
in this position it was clear that okay
nikolic maybe wasn't entirely sure what
to do like white has essentially run out
of like useful improving moves or very
like clearly useful improving moves and
I think this was a point where white
just didn't find the right plan and then
it was black who had all the active play
and because this was blitz it was even
more more difficult for white to come up
with a plan quickly and there's actually
a YouTube video
of of this game being played like live
over the board and we can see like from
this position Carlson has used like very
little time and the college was already
beginning to think and the Nikolic went
ahead here and played Queen e1 which
it's not the most impressive move the
idea was to eventually play Bishop a5
but it did not work out at all
Carlson just improves Queen e7 might be
one sad move but unleashing the bishop
to to come to a5 Carlsen goes for e5 and
this is just such a principled approach
like when your opponent's pieces are
passive and like light is already
retreating then you should look to open
up the center and e5 is very nice
because ok blacks pieces are just so
harmonious and White's pieces are just I
mean I feel bad calling them garbage but
that's essentially what they are and
when the center opens up like that all
the tactics are gonna favor black so
Bishop a5 was played going after the the
C pawn Carlson had no fear and he just
ignores the C pawn being attacked takes
on g4 and now why does is faced with a
difficult decision because if I take t4
then White's just left with an isolated
Queens pawn
that's very nice positional play for a
black what Nikolic played was a knight
take d4 but this was even worse and from
this position if I'm not mistaken black
is already winning material by force and
this is actually a good moment like for
people who are really engaged with this
if you want to pause your video and find
a forcing way for black to win material
there's uh there's a nice combination
here so the combination just involves a
few forcing moves the first one being a
maiden one threats Queen B five and the
point is that h2 is a target but also b2
and after a white defends with g3
Carlsen just plays c5 and White's
position is already falling apart the
knight has to move
and b2 will hang an account you're
attacking move like f4 never works
because of Queen take e3 so the game
ended really quickly like the game just
lasted six or seven more moves after
Bishop f3 Bishop take f3 might take a
three free pawn on b2 colony for rook
Yeats and like White has no compensation
from the pawn if anything black is the
one with more active place still like
White's pieces are just not coordinating
coordinating at all neither b1
undeveloped Bishop on e5 staring into
empty space Queen on e1 blocks in the
rook
meanwhile at both a 4 and a 2 are not
sufficiently defended so what happened
the game was just very smooth for
Carlsen and in the words of Maurice
Ashley Queen take a to Pawnee v one last
trick didn't work at all Queen d5 was
very nice making use of the pin now the
pawn on e5 and the 911 three are
attacked Queen D 1.81 and then Bishop
take E 5 and black is just up three
pawns as rare to see such a strong
grandmaster Nikolic raided I think in
the mid 2500 I mean he just went down
incredibly easy to talk Carlsen I mean
okay it is Magnus Carlsen it is blitz
but still in a Queen's Gambit opening
usually why this supposed to have a
solid position from early on and we can
see that in this game a6 was was a nice
way to not only get out of opening
theory but to just have like a very
simple and easy structure to play and I
think it's a it's a type of move that I
wouldn't be surprised if it becomes more
trendy and in the coming years I mean at
least it maybe not at like the highest
Grandmaster level play but at lower
levels I think it's a very reasonable
way to to treat the position if we look
at the other moves here one of the main
ideas is that if Knight f6 is played so
early it allows Bishop g5 so this is
another idea for a black to
waits on committing the pieces and and
go for this early queenside play one
more thing I want to mention which I
don't think I don't think I even like
prepared but I should point out that I
move like c5 might look attractive for
lights but this just walks into b6 and
they move like b4 can be met with with a
five and this is actually a very
fundamental sequence like it that at the
beginner level I remember when I was
first starting out chess realizing that
the c5 move walks into B six and A five
and this is just a very strong way
strong positional approach for black to
to tear down White's queenside pawns so
no I covered a lot of lines but
hopefully uh hopefully viewers found
this useful and maybe can be inspired to
uh to play a bit more creatively like
Carlson so I'll leave it at that if
anyone has any questions leave a message
below in the comments and I'll see you
guys in the next video